le tribunal de commerce de tours des
ménages de ses locaux rue berthelot un
projet dans les cartons depuis six ans
qui était prévu au mois de novembre dans
leur bail actuel mais les retards des
travaux du tribunal judiciaire ont remis
en cause la possibilité d'avoir un lieu
où s'installer
les explications de samuel colin la
salle d'audience qu'il est la salle
historique donne un tribunal de commerce
qu'on va bientôt quitter la fin d'une
aventure commencée en 1803
d'un côté la partie historique du
tribunal appartient au département
l'autre la partie moderne où est situé
le greffe revient à un promoteur
immobilier
le bail des juges bénévoles se termine
le 26 novembre mais les relations avec
le nouveau propriétaire ne sont pas au
beau fixe
ils seraient pressés de les voir partir
je sais pas comment vous pouvez tenir
des audiences avec 14 degrés avec des
gens qui attendent trois heures quatre
heures dans la salle d'audience sans
bouger on amène une mini pelle dans la
voix la journée on creuse un trou devant
la sortie du parking on coupe
l'électricité de la porta battante du
parking aux fins des plaisanteries de ce
style là sauf que le tribunal de
commerce n'a pas encore son point de
chute
le projet initial déménagé rue edouard
vaillant en lieu et place du tribunal
d'instance
ce dernier retourne place jean jaurès
comme le prévoit la réforme de la
justice et sa fusion des tribunaux
civils
mais à tour les travaux de rénovation du
palais de justice prenne du retard
depuis deux ans donc on sait que les
locaux ici seront livrés au 1er avril
dans la partie basse à xive au public
c'est à dire l'accueil et la salle
d'audience et appartements on a récupéré
cette deuxième salle d'audience
on pouvait libérer locaux de l'instance
horie vaillant parce que ça nous
permettait du coup de tenir les
audiences qui étaient tenus là bas dans
une salle d'audience dédié ici les
locaux rue edouard vaillant seront
entièrement libéré début juillet des
travaux d'aménagement vont ensuite être
fait et la première audience du tribunal
de commerce devrait se tenir début
octobre